hello there ladies and some gentlemen
it's me Deadpool check this out a hush
falls over the crowd as rookie sensation
Deadpool lines up the shot form looks
good why the fancy red suit mr. pool
when a dude tries to make you a super
slave and kidnaps your future baby mama
the time has come to be a superhero cue
the music
this is taking unsportsmanlike conduct
to our whole new level I am very turned
on right now
hey youtubers is Charlie new Deadpool
footage we are now within the one month
window before the movie comes out and
Deadpool's 25th anniversary is next
month just in case you've never read the
comics before Deadpool started out
inside the New Mutants title he was
created by Rob Liefeld and Fabien this
way sir
they usually when people think a
Deadpool they think of Rob Liefeld
Liefeld tells hilarious stories about
their collaboration whenever they were
first creating the character like dude
seriously this is a total ripoff of
Deathstroke oh yeah maybe I should
change it a little bit more life l did
set out to create a Deathstroke type
character like trying to one-up
Deathstroke as a character when he
created Deadpool just a more hardcore
version of Slade Wilson which is why
Deadpool's name is wade wilson you get
the idea total went up on on DC but he
started out as this really minor
character and he was most definitely
written as a super villain more recent
comics like Wolverine and The Avengers
with with the Evan character have used
arcs to humanize Deadpool a little bit
more he's a little softer nowadays back
in the early 90s when he debuted he was
way more hardcore really I think the
changes in the character are just due to
his broadening audience like they they
want to spread Deadpool to the masses so
you wind up sanding some of the edges
off but if you do like the crazier
darker version of Deadpool you can
always go back and read those classic
comics Marvel and DC are both trying to
do the same thing right now kind of
reinvigorate their comics and spread
them to a new audience like you have the
all-new Avengers they're trying to get
people who would never read comics but
go to see these movies and really enjoy
them to start reading comics so that's
how you wind up with quirky stuff like
gwenpool
and if you don't know what gwenpool is
it's basically Gwen Stacy as the
Deadpool character Marvel said that
spider Gwen was so successful that they
were like okay we'll try gwen stacy with
another character and it's gonna be Gwen
pool so either you'll love it or you'll
think it's complete sacrilege you may
have noticed they're kind of doing the
exact same thing with the marketing of
the Deadpool movie they're basically
trying to get people that normally
wouldn't go see a Deadpool movie to go
see it which is why they have all this
comedy love story stuff going on there
was actually this banner they released
to make it look like a love story
because they're releasing the film near
Valentine's Day they're just there
playing on the fact that it's a love
story but yeah this is the total comic
book movie total Deadpool so let me know
in the comments if you have a relative
or a friend who doesn't know what
Deadpool is but saw this marketing and
is like all
you know what a nice Valentine's Day
movie let's go see without realizing
that it's gonna be this really bloody
hard our comic book film you can always
tell who the big comic book fans are by
the way they react to the marketing of
these films like oh my god I don't
understand what's going on here like
some people totally get the joke some
people just take it at face value like
oh what a nice love story so if you have
any funny stories about people reacting
to these weird Deadpool marketing
teasers let me know in the comments
that's one of the best parts about
getting ready for big movies like this
just seeing the funny stuff that they
try to do to market the films even if
the Deadpool movie is just okay it's not
like the best thing to ever happen to
cinema I feel like the marketing team is
way better than the marketing team for
the x-men films the problem with the
x-men films is that it's such a big
money earner for Fox that they really
have to water down the characters it has
to appeal to the most broad audience
ever so it's a lot harder for them to do
funny teasers like this but don't you
agree that Fox should try some of this
crazy Deadpool marketing stuff with
their x-men franchise I feel like it'd
be a lot more fun
Deadpool graffitiing the [ __ ] out of
x-men posters stealing Wolverines beard
making inappropriate jokes with the
female x-men till they punt him across
the state it's just that I feel like
they're more worried about offending
people with their x-men franchise and
it's just too precious to them Deadpool
by his very nature is offensive so you
don't have to worry about that if he
doesn't offend you a little bit he's not
doing his job so my hope is is the
Deadpool continues for a long time and
even if they don't do a sequel right
away which I kind of think that they
will they'll use him in some of the
other films they're already working on
their x-force film they said they're
developing a new mutants movie last year
and Rob Liefeld was on Twitter the other
night during the Golden Globes saying
hey jon hamm how about you be cable
cable Jon Hamm that would be the most
amazing thing ever yeah he's a little
old but that's kind of the idea with the
cable character you first see him when
he's an old man even though he's the
child of Jean Grey and Scott Summers so
you get the idea these teenage
characters meet their old man's son like
oh my god WTF wouldn't that be funny if
sophie Turner turned around met her son
and her son was Jon Hamm and I do think
the idea is to have cable be the lead of
that x-force film but they they haven't
announced anything official yet I'll
totally do a video for it whatever it
comes so be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's going to be plenty
more Deadpool in the next month
there's a whole bunch of Star Wars Han
Solo news happening so that's gonna be
my next video while you guys wait for
that you can click here for all my
Deadpool videos and you can click here
to learn all about the thor ragnarok
villain and black panther thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you